in early 2019 robert pattinson was
announced as the new caped crusader for
matt reeves highly anticipated
adaptation
the batman and well the internet they
had thoughts
which is pretty much par for the course
whenever someone is cast in a batman
movie or
any superhero movie it's like ben
affleck's gonna be batman the first one
just goes
no and being as robert pattinson's most
recognizable role to date was this
this is the skin of the killer bill we
can understand
the initial skepticism more recently
though that skepticism
has shifted to cautious optimism as
people have discovered the non-twilight
parts
of pattinson's career as the movie heads
back into production
we thought we'd ask how did robert
pattinson go from twilight to the batman
and why do we and a lot of initial
haters now think he's the perfect choice
to do this we really have to take a look
back before we examine how robert
pattinson emerged as the front runner in
the most coveted superhero role like
ever we have to examine what makes a
good superhero on the big screen
and how that's evolved over the years
christopher reeves
really kicked things off with superman
in the late 70s
yeah we're really going back that far
but our idea of a modern day superhero
really doesn't take effect until the
2000s when superhero movies
dominated the mainstream blockbuster
season prior to the 2000s
studios looking to cast a superhero or a
superhero villain
tended to go straight to big name movie
stars and just put them in shiny suits
sometimes those suits had nipples
studios
thought if you're gonna be able to sell
these movies to mcdonald's and
mastercard
you gotta have big names and they were
right
for the most part big names equaled big
dollars at the box office
but when they assembled the team for the
2000s x-men
the previous formula for what made a
superhero completely
well mutated by employing an inventive
mix of award winners and prestigious
actors with newcomers and
not really including any marquee names
x-men set itself
apart from all other superhero movies
and it was a huge success
okay halle berry was a big time star but
she also pretty much told us why she was
cast and a couple of years later
sam raimi would take that new casting
formula even further with spider-man
picking critical darling toby maguire no
marquee name at the time
to play peter parker after 2000 it
helped more to have an oscar nom than
100 million dollar movie behind you
if you wanted a studio to put you in
spandex this is not to say hollywood
abandoned the movie star formula
altogether
but as we get into the mid-2000s that
strategy was yielding diminishing
returns
and right as the superhero genre is
really taking off and studios are
rethinking who to cast as their world
savers
robert pattinson starts acting cast as
reese witherspoon's son in vanity fair
yes the same rhys who would play his
love interest just seven years later
which is
not weird at all pattinson's role for
vanity fair was unceremoniously cut at
the last minute
the casting director for that film
reportedly felt so bad that they cast
him as the overcharming cedric diggory
in harry potter and the goblet of fire
so i was quite glad i got cut in the end
after bouncing around some forgettable
indies in 2007
robert pattinson auditioned for the role
of edward cullen
in twilight never expecting it to be a
blockbuster hit and thinking it would
just be another forgettable indie
pattinson was then
inadvertently thrust into one of the
biggest franchises
to ever hit tween girls walls and the
pages of tumblr
[Applause]
then twilight began breaking records in
hall h and
at the box office making pattinson the
exact kind of movie star that would have
been perfect for a superhero movie
once upon a time while our paths churned
out twilight sequels and
subtly shaded the film in the fandom in
interviews every chance he got did your
twilight experience turn out to be what
you expected
over in superhero land something
interesting is taking flight
marvel and christopher nolan leaned into
the x-men model by hiring actors actors
and unknowns
and both start dominating at the box
office
although these are household names now
looking back on the faces of superhero
movies from this time it was more of a
who's who
of who's that back then robert downey jr
was
mostly known for his arrest record chris
helmsworth was an aussie with a barely
there star trek cameo
jennifer lawrence had been nominated for
an oscar but for a film that was
outgrossed by piranha 3d
and henry cavill before man of steel he
was best
known for playing the only character to
have more bed partners than henry viii
on the tudors but back to our new batman
when pattinson left the twilight zone in
2012
after four films and 3.3 billion dollars
at the box office
he could essentially do anything he
wanted and what he wanted to do
was work with some of the most
innovative indie and avant-garde
directors out there
he worked with names like warner herzog
david cronenberg
david michod claire denis james gray the
safety brothers
and robert edgars avoiding anything big
budget or high profile
by not auditioning because he's bad at
it and essentially hounding the
directors he admired
pattinson amassed an impressive
filmography of varied roles
as well as critical acclaim and a
reputation of someone with taste that
many creative directors sought out this
was also the moment that studios started
hiring auteur directors to helm
superhero
films this was not to say that every
effort was the dark knight
but in this time frame the most
successful efforts for fans
and critics shied away from big movie
stars and yes
we are marking justice league as a
lackluster effort but
we are reserving final judgment until we
see the snyder cup
if all this auteur stuff is sounding
somewhat familiar
let us remind you of these award-winning
actors who also eventually chose to play
comic book characters
or at least i think that's what tom
hardy was doing in venom i'm still not
quite sure
[Music]
so this brings us around to the time we
found out robert pattinson would be
our next batman from what we know about
the batman
weird arturism and a bit of weirdness in
the cape and cal
is exactly what the film needs this is
not going to be an early 2000s superhero
flick
rumored to follow the plot of the long
halloween this new batman is more of a
mob detective movie
don't look for too many all out brawls
which is probably a good thing since
pattinson said that he doesn't plan to
work out for the role
perish the thought with that in mind
pattinson's unique filmography
actually gives us a ton of evidence as
to why he was perfectly cast
in the certified fresh high life as an
abandoned astronaut floating aimlessly
in space
pattinson showed his ability to be
captivating in a psychological thriller
as the brooding young billionaire riding
around new york for cronenberg's
cosmopolis
he gives us a tiny peek into what he
could bring to a young bruce wayne
and as the affluent pioneer bent on
wooing his lady love no matter the cost
for damsel he shows us how he can
portray bruce wayne's fanatical quest to
seek justice
by any means necessary it's hard to know
what made matt reeves think pattinson
would be perfect for the role
well besides the killer jawline but you
can see how pattinson
gained an edge by simply being as weird
as possible
and i mean he was really weird
but again being uber weird is something
men who successfully don the cape and
cal
kinda have in common
i mean we get it if you haven't been
following his filmography
and you heard the sparkle vamp was gonna
be bruce wayne you were likely
but very few people knew that heath
ledger would be able to bring macabre
gravitas to the joker
that michael keaton could pull off the
aloof and mysterious but ultra suave
sometimes love struck billionaire or
that hugh jackman could give a character
that he'd been playing for almost two
decades
the heartbreaking swan song of a warrior
that's seen
way too many battles
still makes me cry we might have guessed
that ryan reynolds could have quipped
and joked his way to a pitch-perfect
deadpool but we doubt even
he thought it would be as awesome as it
was chris evans himself was doubtful in
his ability to pull off the perpetually
patriotic and wholesome captain america
and thank god they convinced him
otherwise but does anyone remember the
fact that it took ryan reynolds
three films to get a quippy superhero
performance to work
just saying more than anything what
makes pattinson perfect for batman
is what he's not clooney kilmer and
affleck brought
plenty of star power but they left fans
and critics cold
from the drunken mermaid loving light
keeper to the charismatic bank robber to
the criminal astronaut
to the hilariously offensive monarch to
the post-apocalyptic survivor who hums
pop ballads
pattinson has proved his dogged
commitment to finding interesting
characters
no matter where they lie and all that
work solidified to make casting patents
in his batman
a compelling and inspired choice right
around the time that warner brothers was
looking for a new young actor to play
bruce wayne
knowing all this it kind of makes sense
to cast a man who went on the today show
and lied about dead clowns first time i
went to a circus somebody died one of
the clowns died
and he totally lied about those dead
clowns
honestly in the end the only thing i'm
looking forward to
more than the film is pattinson on the
batman press tour
that in the snack shop that was not
superhero they got a very pronounced gag
reflex
they wrapped him big big tub no i just
always thought like did you ever see
this movie corky romano i used to be
friends with all the other hookers who
live down the street
sometimes sometimes let your freak flag
fly my boy
let it fly